Hello everyone and welcome to another video. The idea for this video occurred to me randomly
this morning while I was in the shower, so cannot guarantee that it'll be the greatest
video I've ever made, but hopefully it turns out halfway decent. Now those of you who are
in touch with the chess world probably know that the Pro Chess League, also known as the PCL,
has completed its second week of regular season action. The PCL is a rapid team competition that's
held on chess.com. It features some of the strongest teams ever assembled across the
entire world. A lot of the top players are participating. Magnus Carlsen, a pretty unknown
player representing the Canada Chess Brass, Hikaru Nakamura, is also playing for the Gotham
Knights, Levi Rosman's New York team. I'm also playing for my hometown team, the Charlotte
Cobras. Unfortunately, we have lost our first two matches, and if you lose three matches in the
regular season, you're out of the PCL, so our back is against the wall and we're going to keep
fighting next week. You should definitely tune in. The matches happen Tuesday, Wednesday,
Thursday, and Friday, and I will link in the description to this video an article,
an informational article, that contains all of the info and schedule that you need to know.
It's broadcast on Twitch and on YouTube. I'm mostly commentating when I'm not playing,
so the PCL is definitely worth a watch if you haven't already tuned in. But the point of this
video isn't just to chill out for the PCL. I think there's also an instructive component.
Now, what I've done for the last couple of hours is sift through all of the games from the first
two weeks with an eye toward finding some of the most instructive endgames. In particular,
I like the endgames that occur in rapid games because both players, by the time move 40 rolls
around, usually have just a couple of seconds on their clock. So you actually see a lot of
very strong players committing uncharacteristic mistakes in the endgame, which they wouldn't make
if they had more time on the clock. We know that the best way to learn is from the mistakes of
others. It's a lot more painful than learning from your own mistake. So what I've done for
this video is assemble the five most instructive and most entertaining endgames that we saw in the
first two weeks of the Pro Chess League. We're going to look at these endgames one by one.
These aren't just pawn endgames or rook endgames. Endgames of various kinds. My endgame series is
still going to continue. So this is kind of a supplementary video that will hopefully give you
some more general advice on playing the endgame. I play my cards right. Hopefully both more advanced
players will benefit as well as newer players. I'll try to share a couple of general pieces of
endgame feedback and I'll give you plenty of opportunities to pause the video and test your
tactical skills and of course your overall endgame skills as well. So we'll get through as many games
as we can. I have five prepared, but if the video is going too long, we might only get to three or
four. So without further ado, let's jump in and start with a pretty basic, but nonetheless very
instructive example. And right before we jump in, just wanted to clarify that I don't have the time
to cover every single detail of these endgames. So I absolutely encourage you to analyze along
with me. If you have questions, you can leave them in the comments, but you can also analyze
with an engine. So I will gloss over some variations that otherwise I would include
just because I want to kind of get through the main points. I want to hit on the main
instructive points of each game and I want to get through as many games as we can. So here we go.
Our first example is an endgame that happened in a game between a very strong Indian Grandmaster
Narayanan, who was facing International Master De Monte Cornet. And Cornet had played a fantastic
game defending against a raging initiative for like 30 moves. And by move 44, they reached the
endgame that is in front of you. This is a same colored Bishop endgame. Obviously we haven't
gotten there yet in my endgame series, but you evaluate these types of endgames much the same
that you would any other endgame like a Pawn endgame or Rook endgame. You calculate the material,
you take a look at which side has the more active pieces, and you examine both sides potential
for creating passed Pawns. And this is a pretty elementary type of endgame because the Pawn
structure is largely symmetrical on both flanks. Neither side has the capacity to create a passed
Pawn, but it's very clear that White has the domination when it comes to piece activity.
White's pieces, both the King and the Bishop, are a lot more active than their counterparts,
particularly White's King, which is oh so close to infiltrating either the Queen's side or the
King's side. Black's King is just holding White's King at bay. The Kings are actually in opposition.
White's Bishop is also more active than it's vis-a-vis because it's pressuring the f7 Pawn.
That is a long-term target. When you're looking at same colored Bishop endgames,
you generally want your opponent's Pawns to be on the same color of your Bishop because then
those Pawns are a lot easier to attack. And if Black's King steps away, then White wins
the game immediately with King f6 picking up both of the King's side Pawns. But of course,
all of these general considerations are subsumed by concrete analysis. And often what happens is
that you look at an endgame and you feel like one side has got to be winning because the pieces are
much more active. But you actually have to calculate concretely. A fortress can completely
nullify all of these general positional considerations, which is actually the case
here. For all of White's advantages, there is absolutely no way for White to infiltrate unless
Black is forced to move her King. And Black is not forced to move her King. Black has a Bishop.
The Bishop has plenty of squares. And all Black has to do to draw this game is just shuffle the
Bishop really on any square as long as you don't allow White's King to infiltrate d5 and c6. So
Bishop b7, for example, is perhaps the easiest way to draw. White is powerless, right? Bringing the
King back doesn't help because c5 is covered by the Pawn. b4 is futile as well. Black will simply
trade and play a move like Bishop c6. That doesn't help. The only tricky move that White can try
is Bishop d5 offering an exchange of Bishops. And as you'll see in the night endgame videos,
Bishop endgame videos, another very important aspect of good endgame technique is the constant
evaluation of what happens in the event that the minor pieces are traded, right? You always have
to keep your peripheral vision on who benefits in the event of a Pawn endgame because trades
are so common. And here it may appear that White has to be winning in the Pawn endgame.
But in fact, White isn't. Black can draw by declining the trade with a move like Bishop c8.
But even taking on d5 results in an immediate draw because after King d7, Black maintains the
opposition. It may seem that with a move b4, White is forcing Black into Zugzwang because after ab4,
ab4, Black runs out of waiting moves. Remember from the Pawn endgame video, Black has to move
for King. If b5, then of course King c5. But the specifics of the position, again, always supersede
these general considerations. And it turns out that after King c7, it's actually a pretty
elementary draw because White cannot go King e6. The f7 Pawn is the unsung hero of Black's
entire defensive construction. White has to take the roundabout route, but Black is in time to make
it to e8. You don't care how passive your King is. White has nothing to attack. King g7 is similarly
futile because after King e7, it doesn't matter who has the opposition. Black will just shuffle
between e8 and e7 ad infinitum. White will never be able to play h5. And even if White
quote-unquote gets the opposition, it's not going to matter because if White drops back to f6,
Black then reclaims the opposition and pursues White's King to the edge of the world. No matter
where it goes, Black's King is right there and this is an obvious drop. But Cornette, with just
a couple of seconds left on her clock, makes a very understandable move. And this move violates
a rule that my coach shared with me many, many years ago. It's a rule that sounds incredibly
general. It sounds vacuous. It sounds like it, you know, is this really an effective way to play
the endgame? And yet it is, right? My experience has convinced me that this rule is incredibly
enduring and effective across a wide variety of endgames. And the rule simply states that you
should not make unnecessary pawn moves in the endgame. Put another way, every pawn that you
move in the endgame, you should have a clear reason that you're moving it. And creating a
one-move threat is not a reason. Grabbing space isn't really a valid reason to move a pawn in the
endgame. And the reason that you have to be so careful about pawn moves is because they're
tremendously weakening when you don't have a lot of pieces left. When you move a pawn in the
endgame, you are by definition weakening squares. But more importantly, you're often bringing the
pawn onto a more vulnerable square. The further the pawns go from your side of the board, the
harder they are to defend. And when you don't have a lot of pieces left, you might end up losing
those pawns. This is exactly what happens here. Cornette plays the move b5. And this is a decisive
mistake because it puts the pawn on a light square, where it can be much more easily attacked
not only by White's bishop, but also by White's king, because a pathway has now opened up to the
queen side. So this both makes the pawn more vulnerable and allows White's king to infiltrate
Black's weaknesses with Kd5 and Kc5. First, of course, White will have to get this bishop off
of c5. The second thing that it does is that now every pawn endgame is going to be losing for Black.
And so Narayanan responds with a very accurate move. He plays the move Bd5. Now the situation
has changed, and in the event of the trade, White is just going to reach c5, and Black will lose
either one or both of her queen side pawns. So, for example, Kd7, Kc5, and Black can try to initiate
the pawn race, but this is like, you know, a Ferrari racing against a Ford. Black is not even
close. And very importantly, anytime Black plays f5, White takes on Poisson. This is called
a deep freeze. The g5 pawn is deep freezing Black's f7 and g6 pawns, making it incredibly
difficult for Black to even get a passed pawn. So the pawn endgame is now out of the question.
Coronet is forced to move her bishop back. And now the second very important phase of White's
winning strategy. Pause the video. This will be your first endgame task. This is a move that is
automatic for good endgame players, but again, you shouldn't feel bad if you get a move wrong,
because that's the whole point. That's why you study endgames. So see if you can figure this
move out in just a couple of seconds. So in same-colored bishop endgames especially,
when you have an opposing pawn that's on the color of your bishop, that's an incredibly valuable
asset, and you want to make sure when possible that things stay that way, this is what White
does with the move b4. This fixes the pawn on a light square, right? It's hard to shoot at a
moving target, and here the pawn will be totally immobilized, and all that White has to do now
is clear the pathway for the king. Once the king reaches c5, the bishop can drop back to the f1 a6
diagonal. White will pick up the pawn and win the game, and that is exactly how things unfold. Black
is totally powerless because she's too passive. After the trade, Cornette waits around with bishop
e8. White drops the bishop back, and there are some interesting subtleties here that I could
delve into, but we'll skip. So here, for example, the most direct way to win would have been the
immediate king d5, but Narayanan was a little bit worried that Black would essentially trade all of
the king side pawns, and once that happens, even if White will win the b5, on which he will,
remember that if there are no other pawns left, then Black could try to give the bishop away for
White's last remaining pawn. King and bishop versus king is a draw. So Narayanan shuffles
his pieces around and avoids this scenario. He first plays bishop e2. He gets his bishop around
to d3, and only now, after Cornette moves her bishop back, king d7, by the way, would have been
a little bit more resilient, but then the king would have infiltrated f6, and White is still
handily winning. But after bishop d7, king d5, White has avoided the situation. If Black plays f6,
then White takes on g6. This is, in fact, what happens, and now White actually keeps
both past pawns alive. fg5, hg5. Now the king slides over to c5. The bishop moves back to d3,
and Black is unable to get to g6 with her king. If Black's bishop moves away from the diagonal,
then White captures with the king, and if Black stays in the diagonal, then White takes the pawn
with the bishop, and because the bishop is hanging, Black is again unable to reach g6.
This is what happened in the game. White returned to d3, and Cornette resigned the game because the
b-pawn is just going to run up the board. The final detail that I wanted to share is an option
that Black had after king to d5. So you might have noticed that rather than playing f6 and
simply giving up the pawn, Black could have tried to create a passer with f5 and forced White into
taking on Passant. But in fact, White has an even easier approach here than taking on Passant,
which does win. This position is winning, even though Black is able to trade all of the pawns.
You can convince yourself of this by using the engine, but White is essentially able to roll
out the red carpet. We will analyze these types of bishop endgames at length in a subsequent
endgame video, but even simpler in this position is actually to go back to e5. Then White's plan
of action is very simple. Black has to stay on this diagonal to keep the pawn defended.
The bishop drops back to e2. Now moving the king is out of the question because White
infiltrates either to f6 or comes around to c5. So Black has to stay with the bishop,
and now White pushes h5. This is a simple breakthrough, breaking down Black's pawn
chain. That's all there is to it. And on the next move, you are going to go around and pick up the
pawn on f5 and essentially get the same type of position that they got in the game. Black has to
simply wait around, bishop g6, and that's it. White takes on f5. The pawn endgame is losing,
and here the simplest is just to get the king over to c5, much like White did in the game and
pick up the second pawn. So f5 was slightly more resilient, but here White could double back to e5
and win the kingside pawn first in the game. Black played f6 and gave up the pawn, but all
of Cornette's problems in this endgame stemmed from that decisive mistake in the initial position.
So do not push unnecessary pawns, and particularly in bishop endgames, you should be very sensitive
about putting your pawns on squares where they can be attacked by the opposing side's bishop.
From White's perspective, I think the most instructive was, first of all, to offer the
bishop trade, right? When a pawn is pushed, the situation changes, and you should reassess what
happens in the event of a trade. But also as important was the move before fixing the pawn
on a light square so that you can more easily attack it with your pieces. And in this way,
Narayanan was able to win the game. Okay, on we go to our second endgame, and these endgames won't
have any particular order. I want to give you a a wide variety of interesting endgame positions.
So let's examine a more tactical endgame. Now, what's funny is that I was commentating this game
live. This was a game between Karina Ambratsumova, International Master, and V. Pranav, a newly
crowned Grandmaster from India, who some people who are watching this should be familiar with.
I've played him a dozen, hundreds of times probably by now in Blitz. Super, super talented player.
And Pranav has the black pieces here, and he is completely winning. He is technically down
an exchange, but he's got two pawns for that exchange. But all of that doesn't matter. Look
at this pawn on d2. It is a passer, and what stands between it and promotion is this miserable
rook on d1. Black's pieces are maximally active, and the winning approach is of course to dislodge
the rook from d1 by attacking it with the knight. So that's exactly what Pranav does. He plays the
obvious move, knight to c3. Now, as a sneak preview, you can see the question mark popping
up on the screen. So you know already that something is wrong with this move. Is there a
way to do the same exact thing but from a different angle? Well, yes there is. The move knight f2 does
indeed win the game for black. If the rook moves, then black simply promotes and emerges up a piece.
If black does not react, then white does not react, then black takes the rook and wins easily.
The quote-unquote most resilient move is queen b7 check, but this is a paper tiger because the
king is able to hide out on h6. And most importantly, consider the placement of black's queen.
It's placed on an ideal position both from an attacking but also from a defensive perspective
because it's guarding the h8 square. So black can safely take white's rook and has nothing to fear
on the king's side. White has one check. It can be easily blocked by the queen, and here white is
simply out of checks. But most importantly, this would be checkmate were it not for the presence
of black's queen. So you should actually keep that in mind because it becomes very important in just
a couple of moves. What could possibly be the downside of doing the same thing from the other
side of the board? Well, once again, white's hand is largely forced, and Ambert Sumovo with her last
seconds finds the correct move. She gives the check on b7. But after king h6, we seem to have
the same exact scenario. Who cares whether the knight is on c3 or f2? It doesn't change anything.
Black's queen is still on the same spot, but this really is the beauty of endgame tactics, right?
Even more so than middle game tactics, endgame tactics really often don't subject themselves
to intuitive logic. Your intuitive part of your brain could be screaming that one thing is the
case, but the tactics often show otherwise. And here it turns out that there is a beautiful,
beautiful difference between the placement of the knight on f2 and on c3 because here white gets
an additional defensive resource, which actually forces black to be the one to find a series of
only moves in order to draw the game, as crazy as that sounds. So great time to pause the video
and figure out the hidden resource that allows white to turn the tables.
So the best way to solve a puzzle like this is probably process of elimination, right? You
literally just consider every legal move, and we already know that a move like queen c8 does not
do the trick. This literally transposes into the same position we had from the knight f2 variation.
So the only difference is that here the knight and the queen are aligned, and white is able to
pin the knight with the crazy move queen b2, which I think is a move which may have even occurred to
Karina. It's not a particularly challenging move in and of itself, right? You're pinning the knight,
which means that knight takes d1 loses the game because black drops the queen. But subconsciously
it's very easy to rule this move out because black has, of course, an intermediate check on f2.
And after the king moves, the knight safely takes the rook, and black wins the game. Wait a second,
what was the queen doing on d4 on that other line? Well, guess what? It was guarding the h8 square.
Here white literally has mate in one. Queen goes from, where did it start? It goes from f3 to b7
to b2 to h8. Ridiculous geometry here by the white queen. And after queen f2, check king h3.
In order to draw the game, black actually has to find the move queen to f3. Everything else
loses because if you play some other move, if you play move like queen e3, then white again goes to
b8 and starts hunting the black king down. This threatens mate on h8. If black tries to defend,
then the deflection sacrifice wins the game. Rook takes d2 is really pretty. Queen d2,
queen h8 is checkmate. And if black defends with the king, then white zigzags her way first to c7,
then to d8. What's the idea of the staircase? Well, now you can pick up the pawn on d2 because
the queen and the rook are linked up. So in this position, black has to find the cold-blooded move
queen f3, which allows white to draw in a variety of ways, the most clinical of which is actually to
still go to b8, threatening the mate on h8. And black has nothing better than to force a perpetual
check with queen g4 and queen e2. Don't go back to the first rank because you give the rook away
with check. Black has nothing better to do. King g7 again loses to the staircase mechanism. So black
would be the one who would have had to be precise after this incredible move, queen b2. And what
this teaches us is that, well, as much of a cliche as this may sound like, you really should never
give up in the endgame. I think a lot of players, they tend to associate endgames with lack of
resources, lack of defensive resources. And you may think of the endgame as a phase of the game
where it's much harder to trick your opponent. And partially that's true, but that doesn't mean
that tactics or mating ideas are absent from the endgame. And when there are queens on the board,
there are always mating patterns. That is just a thing you should hammer into your head.
And can we blame Karina for missing queen b2 with three seconds? Absolutely not. I would have never
found this move. But nonetheless, it exists. And it teaches us a lot about the abundance of tactical
resources, even when they appear to be least likely. Karina played queen h1. And after knight
takes d1, Pranav was obviously able to win the game. He delivered a check on f2 and played queen
e1. It would be nice if the queen could teleport itself to the... I guess that wouldn't have helped
because now black has the equivalent mate on h1. And black made a second queen, easily dodged the
checks and won the game. So really incredible tactical resource in the unlikeliest of moments.
Okay, on we go to our next example. This one is also very, very tactical and very pretty.
It is a game that occurred between two of the stronger teams in the PCL, the Garden State
Passers, who have Samuel Sevim, their board one, and the Levidov Chess Wizards, which is composed
of a lot of very strong Russian and Belarusian GMs, one of whom is Denis Lazovic. He's a very
exciting young player from Belarus. 2541 is his rating, but you can toss that into the trash can.
He's definitely over 2600 strength. So in this game, Lazovic has black against Sevim, and they've
reached the pawn endgame that is in front of you. It is black to play. And once again, as is going
to be the case in all of the endgames that we are examining today, both sides are in acute time
pressure and have mere seconds to make very complicated decisions. So I'll make it a little
bit easier for you. The big question here for black is between keeping the status quo, which
essentially means doing nothing, and what that means in a pawn endgame is moving the king. We've
already learned that you should avoid unnecessary pawn moves, so the default move is king back to
e7. But of course, if you've watched the pawn endgame videos carefully, you should already sense
what the big worry here is for black, which is that the black king, being more passive than its
counterpart, and being the king that is in opposition, is going to get shouldered. It's
going to get zugzwanged continuously, and white is ultimately going to make his way to the kingside
and pick off black's vulnerable kingside pawns. He's going to do that by playing king to c7.
Black, again, is in zugzwang, right? If the king goes back to e8, then white drops back to d6.
This is shouldering. Vice versa, king e8, king e6, king d8. And if black continues to dilly-dally,
well, there we go, right? King e6, king e8, and king f8, and white is already winning the game by
bringing the king down to g7. But upon closer examination, you should realize that black is
not entirely powerless. Black has a lever that he can pull, and he can pull it in a variety of
different moments, and that lever is the pawn breakthrough f5, forcing a mass trade of pawns
and transforming the position into an entirely different type of pawn endgames. Lazovic decides
to pull the lever in the initial position. He plays the move f5 here, and we will start by
considering how the game unfolded. Then, when we finish the analysis, we will go back to the
initial position, and the correct approach will make a lot more sense once you realize why the
move f5 should have been a decisive mistake that lost Lazovic the game. As we will see,
there are many more adventures to be had here. Well, white has to start by trading, initiating
the trades, right? White cannot ignore, because then black will take and create a pass pawn of
his own. So white has to trade, and again, if you ignore, then black will play f4 and e4, and white
will simply lose the game. So Savian accedes to the trades, and we reach this position. So it's
easy to get overwhelmed in these types of pawn endgames, because there's a lot of directions that
the king can take, right? And it gets complicated, but it's actually simpler to break this down than
it appears. This is a pawn race in the making, and the reason I see that quickly is because with
his next move, king to d5, white gets opposition and will ultimately try to dislodge black's king
away from its protection of the e5 pawn using zugzwang. Black's only counterplay in that case
will be to go after the h3 pawn. If both of those pawns are liquidated, we're going to get a pawn
race between the e pawn and the h pawn, but before we get that pawn race, both sides have a series of
waiting moves that they need to exhaust, and this is exactly what happens. Lazovic plays the move e4,
pushing the pawn forward, but Savian freezes the pawn with e3, and hopefully you can see where this
is going, especially if you watched the video on pawn races and waiting moves. Black has only one
waiting move remaining, that is h5, and white completes his waiting moves last, forcing black
into zugzwang. h4 is played, and black's king has to abandon the e4 pawn. Now I should note that
something similar would have happened if black had started with h5 here. White can play h4,
reaching essentially the same position, or white could start with e4 check, and after king f4,
force zugzwang with h4, and again you get the same position from the game. Instead, Lazovic pushed e4,
not exactly the same position, but the nature of the pawn race will be essentially identical. Well,
black has to take the plunge and play king g4. Savian captures on e4, and black captures on h4.
Now the first thing that you need to do in a pawn race is simply count the tempi. Whose pawn
is further advanced? Well, mathematically, black should be the first one to promote in a pawn race.
Like, if you calculate abstractly, white moves the king, black moves the king, e4 h4, e5 h3,
e6 h2, e7 h1. Incidentally, I put the white king on d5, where black will promote with check,
but clearly black should be on the aggressive side of the pawn race. Black should definitely
not be losing here. But you might remember that one of the crucial rules of pawn races is to not
forget that you can use your king not only to assist your pawn, but also to obstruct and slow
down the progress of the enemy pawn. This is particularly true when the opposing side has
a corner pawn and the king is stuck in front of the pawn. The black king cannot move to the right
side of the board. There is no right side of the board. And so the savvy winning move is king e4
to f4. You're taking opposition, but that's not why this move is good. It's good because you're
not allowing black's king to step away from the pawn. Black's king has to remain on the h-file,
and this gives white a very, very important tempo. Sevian uses this tempo to start the progress of
his own pawn. Lazarevic does the same. And here we reach the critical position of this game. Again,
there were about five seconds on the clock for Sam. He took three of them on what may seem like
the most natural move possible, right? Your hand is reaching to make this move, and yet there is
only one way to move, only one way to win. And it involves making what, to me at least,
seems like the most unnatural move, especially if you start calculating. And therein lies the
beauty of pawn endgames in general, but this endgame in particular, because it illustrates
a very, very instructive idea that you have to understand if you want to handle pawn races
successfully. So pause the video. This is a big, big moment. Let's see if you can improve
on Sam Sevian's play and find the winning approach.
Oh, spilled some water on my phone there. So I'm kind of regretting saying that, you know,
the correct move is unnatural, because natural means different things to different people. So
hopefully you were able to toss that in the trash. There are two logical candidate moves for white.
The first is to push the pawn. The second is to try to keep Black's king caged in with the move
king to f3, maintaining opposition and trying to buy yourself as much time as possible for the
progress of your e-pawn. And Sevian makes this move. He plays king f3. And to me, this move seems
more natural, because there doesn't appear to be a downside of the move king f3. You're just forcing
Black's king further down. And if you look at this position carefully, you'll notice that king g1 can
be met with king g4, and white picks up the pawn. So we're home free, e5. Except we're not home free.
The problem is that Black pushes this pawn down to h3. And if white continues to keep Black's king
boxed in, yeah, congratulations, you're going to stop Black from promoting. But what's going to
happen, a scenario that we did explore in the pawn race video, is that Black is now stalemated.
And in order to unstalemate Black, you have to move the king away, allowing Black to step to g1
or g2, and promote his pawn. And in that case, Black promotes first, and is able to eke out the draw.
After e7, this is simply a stalemate. King g3, Black plays king g1. And it's crucial that Black
promotes first, because if white had promoted first, then obviously queen e1 would be checkmate.
But here, Black tosses white's king away from g3, and makes an easy draw. So it turns out
that king f3 is the move which gives away the win, and the correct move is the immediate e5.
Now, how on earth does this work? Because, well, you're allowing king g2. And with his last seconds,
Sam undoubtedly calculated to the position after both sides promote simultaneously.
But it's crucial to remember that just because there are two queens on the board,
does not mean that the game ends. The first thing you need to do is look for skewers.
You should be familiar with a lot of situations. For example, if Black's king were to be on d5
here, white would win the game with a diagonal check, skewering, and picking up the queen.
Here, the situation is different because the king and the queen are adjacent, so queen e4 check
is not effective. It doesn't win Black's queen. Black's king is able to stay pegged to the queen.
But here, the win comes from a different source entirely. Turns out, the Black's king, when it's
this close to the corner, and when the queen is this confined, there is a very important idea that
involves forcing Black's king onto the first rank, and then actually making a quiet preparatory move,
which will lead to inevitable checkmate. The most precise win is queen e2 check.
The king is forced onto g1. King h3 results in maiden two. Queen g4 check, and queen g3 is a
very pretty maiden construction, and one that is worth remembering because the queen is blocking
the king's only escape square. So the king has to take the plunge, and now white plays the
incredibly zen move, king g3. And again, you should sear this position into your memory,
because it occurs very, very frequently in all sorts of pawn races that liquidate into queen
endgames. Black has no checks. Well, Black does have checks, but all of them lose the queen.
There are no stalemate tricks either. If Black gives the check here, of course, taking with the
queen would be foolish, but white takes with the king. Black has king h1. There is no way to stop
the myriad of checkmate threats, no matter where Black's queen moves. It might stop one checkmate
threat, but there will be at least two others that will lead to checkmate. This is an obvious
win for white. So a very instructive example of a situation in which, with just seconds on the
clock, Sam decided that because the pawns promote simultaneously, it's automatically a draw. With
just another five or ten seconds, I think he would have understood that this is a win. Instead,
he tries to keep Black's king confined, but remember that when you do that, and when your
opponent has no other pawns left, there is always going to be the threat of a draw.
Of stalemate. But we're not done with this position. Hopefully, you're able to understand
why white was able to win this game. He didn't win the game. How white would have been able to win
this game. Instead, he played this extra move, king f3, and after king h2, e5, h3, the king
steps into the checking zone of the h-pawn, which means that Black will promote with check.
And actually, if white pushes e6 immediately, then yes, white promotes first, but here Black
promotes with check. This is the other important corollary of the move, king f3. So it's not only
a mistake because it allows Black to stalemate his own king, but also because it steps into the
checking zone of the h-pawn, allowing Black to promote with check and worm his way out of the
confined space that the king finds itself in. So the winning move here was the immediate e5.
Let's rewind back to the initial position, where Lazovic pulled the plug and basically played the
move f5. So instead, the draw was given by the move king e7. And we need to pause after king c7,
king e6, and king d8. Right here, it seems that white is making great progress and getting the
king forcibly to the king side. But in this very instance, it is the proper time to push f5. When
the white king is the furthest away from the e5 pawn, that's when you force the liquidation of
the pawns. And the reason should be pretty clear. If we compare this position to the position which
occurred in the game, and the position which occurred in the game was this one, here the king
is on c6, there the king is on d8. So here the king is able to make contact with the e5 pawn in
one move. But if we compare that to this position, here the white king takes two moves to make
contact with the e5 pawn. Now, why does this matter? Well, this matters because it gives black
an extra tempo to push the h pawn as far down as it'll go, which is another rule of pawn races,
which essentially states that when you're anticipating a pawn race, you should always
try to prepare by pushing your prospective past or it's a bit of a mouthful perspective as in
future past pawn as far as it'll go. You should prepare yourself for the pawn race to economize
and save as many tempi as possible. Here black goes h5, white makes contact with the pawn,
but black is able to drive the pawn to h4. This is what black was not able to do in the game.
This is what black was not able to do in the game. White plays king d5, and now black runs toward
the h3 pawn, and it's pretty easy to establish that here black is able to promote first and
draws the game handily. If white plays in this position e3, trying to block the king's path,
well then black draws with king e4. Now actually white is the one who has to be careful. It's still
a draw, but black will actually end up winning the h3 pawn. So again, if we compare this position,
and of course if white plays h4, then white loses because of king g4. So white simply is not able to
do everything that he needs to do to prevent black from playing h4, make contact with the pawn,
and push the e pawn forward. That extra tempo is the difference between a draw and a loss,
and that is what makes pawn endgames so ridiculously devilishly complicated. It's
these minor differences, but appreciating these minor differences and really delving deeply
into these types of endgames, I think they teach you a lot about how to play pawn endgames,
and they help develop a pretty robust intuition, because a lot of the time when you reach an
endgame like this, you just don't have the time to calculate, and you're inevitably going to make
mistakes, but you're going to minimize the risk of those mistakes if you develop a clear intuition
about what is helpful and how you should generally play in these endgames. So one of the key takeaways
is that you shouldn't think in general blocks, right? It looks like black's king is getting
shouldered, but remember that you don't have to sit idly by. You can often push your pawns,
not unless there's a good reason, but here there is a good reason. But you should try to do it when
the opposing side's king is on the most inconvenient square, and often that involves forcing the king
to initiate the shouldering process, and then once the king has reached the 8th rank, we push f5
because it takes the longest possible time to get back to black's pawn. So it's a little bit
of a clunky explanation, but hopefully you found this endgame pretty entertaining. I love me some
pawn races, and this is no exception. So we're down to two more examples. Let's see if we can
get through both of them. Okay, let's take a look at another bishop endgame. Let's take a look at
another bishop endgame, which occurred in a game between two incredibly strong players, Bogdan
Daniel Daech, Romanian grandmaster who's rated 2700 feet a on the nose, and Georg Mayr, super
solid GM from Germany who's beaten a lot of the top players, and you know the last time this guy
lost the game was like 2003. But here Mayr, who has the black pieces, is on the cusp of losing,
and that's obvious because white is simply up a pawn. White has an extra pawn on e5,
and anytime you're up a pawn in a single minor piece endgame, well that's generally
a pretty good sign. But just a couple of seconds into looking at this position, you should
understand that black is a fortress, right? Again, just like in our first example, it's one thing to
just say that you have an extra pawn, but that doesn't win you the game. You actually need to
make progress, promote that pawn, or otherwise infiltrate with your king, and neither of those
scenarios seems remotely possible. So why is that? Well, one of white's big problems is that the a
pawn is on a light square, so white can't just free roll with the bishop. If you make an inaccurate
move, you're immediately going to allow bishop b3, and this is just an immediate draw. In fact,
in order to draw, white has to immediately give up the e pawn to deflect this bishop back. Obviously
king e6, king g6, and white is fine. And after bishop b6, white has to play bishop d1. So one
little careless move, and white is on the defensive. And that appears to completely hamstring
white's ability to play for a win. The move h6 is okay. It seems to accomplish something,
but that's an illusion because the white king cannot make its way past black's king on f7.
In fact, black can shift the king to e7. Black can do it even now. And this king on e7 is on
a dark square. It can never be checked, and it can never be dislodged, and it's very obvious
that white has zero, zero progress to make. In fact, you already have to be careful because
now black's king is suddenly moving up to e6. So it seems that the most, the wisest strategy is
just to repeat moves. And that's what Bogdan Daniel Dyadz does. He brings his king back,
and they essentially repeat moves. This position is still winning for white, as we'll discuss,
but it results in three-time repetition. They had previously had this position two other times,
which I haven't shown you, but this is where the game was automatically declared a draw
by the server. But let's rewind to the initial position. White has an absolutely gorgeous
winning sequence that once again hammers home the importance of being keenly aware of the role of
tactics even when there are virtually no pieces left on the board. There's a ton of tactics in
pawn endgames. In fact, pawn endgames are virtually only tactics, and we see that here as well. The
winning approach involves understanding that the e5 pawn can be used as a decoy. Now, we saw
something like that in our initial line. Here, white uses it as a decoy, but not because he's
trying to win, because he's trying to avoid losing. But this concept is a very valuable one,
because if black's king is forced away from f7, then white takes the pawn on g7, and the corner
pawn is free to roam about the cabin. But how do you get a situation where you can play e6 without
allowing black to take the pawn with the bishop? Well, this is where you come in. Let's pause the
video and see if you can figure out the winning sequence. If you can generate more than just one
move, if you can generate the entire line, that would be particularly impressive. So feel free
to take a couple of minutes here, and I will in the meantime take a sip of tea and watch you guys
torture yourselves. I remember irrationally getting annoyed at my chess coach when he would
give me a position and tell me 20 minutes of thinking, and then I could hear him making tea
in the background, and he would be putting lemon in and enjoying himself and probably watching
Netflix on the side, and here I was laboring over the position. But hopefully these tasks are a
little bit more enjoyable. The winning move is bishop g4. This should come to you naturally,
because when you have an extra pawn, the idea of trading bishops is very logical,
and the pawn endgame is easy to evaluate. It is totally losing for black. In fact,
you can win this several different ways. The easiest is just to go up and win the g7 pawn.
You can also play king f4. So black has to avoid the bishop trade with the move bishop b3. Now
step two is to use the pawn as a decoy. There it is. Now here's the difference. The king has to,
well, the bishop can take the pawn, but that allows the bishops to be traded, and again,
white wins the resulting pawn endgame. So we're getting somewhere. We're forcing black's king
back to f8. But step three, I think, is actually the hardest thing to see. White is playing with
fire here, because there is no longer any way to defend the a4 pawn. And you might say, oh,
I get it. Let's get our king to g6. Let's get our king to g6, and then let's play e7 check,
and take on g7. But just because you have the passed pawn doesn't mean you win the game.
Does it mean you win the game? Remember that your opponent can actually give away the minor piece,
in many cases, for your only remaining pawn. Here white has another pawn remaining,
but it's hamstrung. It's frozen, and black can easily reach it with his king. So after bishop c2,
I think black is already winning. The engine kind of fluctuates here, but I'm pretty sure black is
already winning, because not only will you not be able to promote, but even if you win the bishop,
black is now suddenly the one who promotes. White can't play bishop e6. So the common technique
often is to play bishop h5 and bishop g6, and dislodge the bishop from the diagonal. But white
is not in time, because black plays a2 and promotes with check. So white actually loses
in this case. So you would not really go into this line if you didn't see the subsequent move.
And this is another opportunity, if you didn't have a clear idea in this position, to figure out
the brilliant follow-up tactic. And I'll pause for just a couple of seconds here as well.
Okay, so the correct approach is another deflection sacrifice. Two deflections in the
span of five moves in an endgame. Here this is a completely different kind of deflection. You're
not trying to deflect the king. You're trying to deflect the g7 pawn, which is not permitting white
to reach the f6 square. That's the promised land. So we now use the h pawn as the decoy.
We're threatening h7. Black has to take, and the king moves into f6. And now e7 is totally
unstoppable. Black can give the bishop away for the pawn. But here it's clear that white is winning,
because you're just going to win the remaining queenside pawns. If black does anything else,
if black takes on a4, then the win is elementary. We give a check, and the king is on a light square,
which is so so valuable here, because the bishop is able to dislodge it, and white promotes a queen.
Nothing that black can do in this situation. Bishop h5 is unstoppable. So bishop takes c6
is technically the most resilient, but it loses the game very straightforwardly as well. Remember,
as a basic point, but still important to note, you should never be afraid of a scenario like this,
and think that black will somehow be able to promote their pawn. You can always just give
the bishop away for the pawn, especially if the king is as far away as it is from the queenside.
I feel like I said that in a New York accent, a pawn. You should, you know, you should, you should
always, you know, you should be, you know, ready to, you know, and give up, you know, the bishop
for pawn, much like I did, you know, against Korpov, you know, in 1984. But, you know, it's
very important. So anyways, I got a little carried away there. But the move h6 is such a great
illustration of the role of unexpected tactics in the endgame, and of the role of just thinking big,
right? You might always, you always want to think in the form, okay, this is what I want to achieve.
And this could be completely unrealistic, right? You should tell yourself, I want to get a king to
f6. And you should not rule out that thought, just because there's a pawn in g7, because
you're often able to do a lot more in endgames than might seem to be the case, because you don't
have a lot of pieces left. And yet, your remaining pieces and pawns are often capable of great things
as they are here. The last thing I'll say is that Black can try to stave off defeat with bishop c2.
And the hasty h takes g7 check actually gives away the win, because here, of course, the king
is no longer able to infiltrate. So all White needs to do is make the patient move bishop h5,
which by this point should be pretty obvious. The point is that after bishop d3, well, now you can
play, there's multiple ways to win, but the simplest is to play hg and e7. Of course, you're
stopping king f7, and White promotes the queen. If Black plays gh, then you transpose back into the
other mating line. So the win here is yielded first by using the threat of the bishop trade
to dislodge the bishop. Here's deflection number one, forcing the king away. And deflection number
two immediately afterward clears the path to the f6 square. There's the concept of mowing the lawn
that I talked about in the advanced topics pawn endgame video, and this is kind of similar where
you use your pawns to clear a path for your king, which then enables your other pawn to promote to a
queen. Okay, so we're at 46 minutes here. What we're going to do is go through the last example
pretty quickly. I could talk about it for ages. We're not going to do that. I'm going to try to
limit myself to five or six minutes. So buckle in. So I'm going to try to hit on the important
points here. And our last endgame is a battle between Jaime Santos La Taza, Spanish Grandmaster,
and Oleksandr Bortnik, a good friend of mine. Incredibly strong blitz and bullet player.
Many of you listening are probably familiar with that name. So Bortnik has the black pieces here.
He also represents the Garden State Passers, who have Sam Sevian, who we saw just earlier on board
one. Now it is White to play in this position. Jaime Santos La Taza has the move, and he has the
advantage. That part is obvious because he's got the only passed pawn. And he also has the capacity
to capture the pawn on g6 if he so desires. But what you should notice here also is that Black's
king is quite far away from White's a-pawn. So Jaime Santos La Taza, who was not in time pressure,
he was the only player of all of the ones we looked at today who was not in time pressure.
And ironically, he makes the fastest move of anybody. He takes two seconds on his next move,
and he pushes the pawn up to a5. And amazingly, this ridiculously natural move gives away the win.
Right? How natural is it just to push the pawn forward? It seems self-evident that Black is not
able to stop this pawn. And yet this move enables Black to achieve a beautiful, beautiful draw,
which Bortnik finds he was in serious time pressure. And yet he was able to find the
drawing idea. So first, let's take a look at the draw. Then we'll rewind and consider how White
should have proceeded. There is a very narrow path actually to winning this game. So what you
should immediately rule out is a move like rook to a2, because this is a lost cause. You're allowing
a6. And ultimately, White is just going to go around with his king. If Black tries to keep
White's king at bay, then White starts mopping up the king's side pawns. And you're not going to be
able to give perpetual check here, because the king will always be able to zigzag its way behind
the pawn. You're going to lose the g4 pawn. And I'll leave this to you to figure out. But you're
going to lose the game pretty straightforwardly here. So Black needs something with a little bit
more meat on the bone. And the only source of counterplay that Black has are the g pawns.
But the g pawns are restricted. So by process of elimination, Sasha plays rook to g2. And he told
me that when he played this move, he still didn't fully see how he was going to draw the game. But
he figured he had no other defensive ideas. And that is a very effective method, especially in
time pressure. White continues pushing. He takes the pawn. White continues pushing. And the game
seems to be over. Because if Black stops the pawn from behind, as you're supposed to do,
White blocks the rook with rook a6. That's it. Black's pawn is one tempo short. g3,
aid queen, stopping g2. And if Black gives the check, then the king steps away anywhere. And
again, promotion is unstoppable. And yet it is in this position that Black has just an incredible
resource, which is so easy to miss when you're calculating from a distance. Again, use process
of elimination. And you should find this move very, very quickly. Pause the video,
maybe for one last time, and see what you can come up with here.
Okay, so there's literally only one other thing that you can do.
Rook b3 check. A check can be such an effective method in endgames, right? You don't even have
to understand exactly what the check does. But it often dislodges your opponent's king. And
that opens up a wealth of new defensive possibilities. So here's the rub. If White
goes to c6, now Black plays rook a3. And suddenly there is no more rook a6. White can play king b7.
But now Black gets the requisite tempo that he needs in order to push the pawn one square further.
If White plays rook a6 now, then Black trades and promotes simultaneously. Incidentally,
Black can also sack the rook immediately, and the g-pawn secures the draw. This is a classic
scenario. We will talk about this in a dedicated rook versus pawn video, or multiple videos,
because these endgames can get very complicated. But here it's very easy to establish that the
threat of promotion forces White to give away the rook for the pawn, or to keep checking. But the
king is always going to go back to the pawn when necessary, and threaten g1 equals queen.
So that is an elementary draw. La Tassa finds the only way to keep the game going,
and that's king to a4, covering the squares on the a-file. Bortnick has to take the rook,
and White promotes to a queen. And you might be aware that queen versus rook is winning for the
queen, right? It's a theoretical win. But here there are these two additional pawns. So I think
a lot of players, if they have Black here, would be tempted to just try to push the pawns. But
that's actually the last thing that you want to do, first of all, because this blunders the rook.
But even if it didn't, right, by pushing the pawns back to our initial endgame principle,
don't push pawns unnecessarily, because you're going to end up weakening them. If White can win
one of the pawns, then likely he is going to win the second one. Bortnick plays the very level
headed move, rook f6. Common defensive technique when you've got a rook against the queen,
try to keep your rook and your king as close together as possible, because that minimizes
the risk of forks, as it does here. La Tassa brings his king over. Bortnick swings his queen
over to the g-file. And now comes the main aspect of this endgame. Black not only has a fortress,
it's not one of those fortresses where, you know, you got to find a new move every time.
Literally, Black's rook goes between f3 and f5. Between f3 and f5. It's a beautiful construction,
and it's so unusual. These doubled pawns create two anchor squares on the f-file. What's important
about the f-file is that it keeps White's king permanently cut off on this side of the board.
White cannot make any progress, and White cannot cause Zugzwang, because every time he tries,
Black just shifts the rook from f3 to f5. There is no checkmating pattern, because the king will
always have the g5 square, or the h6 square, or some sort of square. White has no way to set up
a mating construction. If White's king had been on g3, then queen h4 would be checkmate. White's
king can never get onto the f-file, and after a couple of useless moves, Santos La Tassa simply
offered a draw. There's nothing to play for, because Black can literally pre-move rook f3
and rook f5 until the end of humanity. So, it's just, again, demonstrates the resilience that you
often see in endgames, even with like one piece left on the board. So, if we rewind back to the
start, the last thing that I want to mention is the winning line, which does in fact start with
the only other logical move, and that's rook takes g6. Now, Santos rejected this move, I think,
because he feared king f5, and he thought that taking this useless pawn on g6 would only lose
some tempi for White, and it would allow Black to generate counterplay. Ironically, that's precisely
what he allowed with the move a5. Here, the winning move is actually rook to d6. Simple idea.
Rook g2 is just met with rook d3. Sometimes, you want to make a couple of defensive moves,
and now the game is over. Now the game is over. Black can try to stave off defeat,
but ultimately, White can win this in a variety of ways, such as bringing the king closer,
and then blocking the b-file, and then at the right moment, the a-file, and the pawn is
essentially home free. So, that doesn't do all that much. There is nothing else that Black can
do. If he tries king e4, then the clinical move is actually rook d6 to f6. I really like this
geometry. You go rook takes g6 to d6 to f6, cutting off the king, and you're aiming for f4.
You want to win the second pawn, which is going to make the winning task so much easier. Black
cannot stop rook f4. Even after king d5, you can throw in a check to get Black off of the
opposition. Now you play rook f4, and that's it. Black loses the second pawn, and again,
I'll leave it up to you to figure out how to win that ensuing position, but it's totally winning.
So, rook d6 is the winning move here. Rook to c6 may seem to do the same thing, but it allows Black
to give this additional check on b2. Here, if the king moves back, then Black can play rook to g2,
and the pathway to the c3 square is blocked. That is why only rook d6 wins the game. Not rook c6,
definitely not something like rook g8, because this simply blunders the pawn, much like White
did in the game. But really, the highlight of this endgame is that a move as natural as a5
enables Black to save the draw. Always remember, a check, even if you don't know exactly why it's
played, can be such an effective defensive tool in the endgame. In this case, it dislodges the
king, and no matter where it goes, Black either stops the pawn from behind, or, as in the game,
wins White's rook, and then sets up a beautiful fortress, a very unusual fortress, that features
two doubled pawns. I have actually never seen this before. I was flipping out during the commentary,
and you know, you should never just assume that queen versus rook positions are always going to
be winning. If there are a couple of pawns on the board, then you actually often can set up some
sort of impregnable fortress. That is what Portnick did in this game to save an important
half point for the Garden State Passers, who ended up winning their match against the Spanish Maniac
Shrimps, who my team, the Charlotte team, is facing next week. We go full circle. And on that note,
folks, this video did go a little bit longer than I anticipated, but that's okay. We were able to go
through all five of our instructive endgames. We started with a simple illustration of the
potential danger of making unnecessary pawn moves and creating additional weaknesses.
Then, we took a look at a fascinating tactical endgame. Never underestimate the power of your
few remaining pieces to generate mating threats. Queen b7, queen b2 there would have drawn the
game. Then we looked at the pawn endgame and discovered the power of timing the pawn advance
correctly. You often want to time the pawn breakthrough to the point where your opponent's
king is on the most inferior square. Also, pawn races, simultaneous promotions, we had it all in
this endgame. Then we took a look at the double deflection that White could have used in this
game to win, e6 and then h6. And finally, we concluded with the rook endgame. No endgame video
would be complete without a rook endgame in which White falls for the temptation of making a natural
move. Always calculate. Always look at each endgame concretely whenever possible. Hopefully,
you enjoyed this endgame exposition. I know that some of these examples were pretty complicated,
but thank you very much for watching. The endgame series will continue as well with another knight
versus pawns video. And if this video is well received, I am more than happy to do more of these
kind of endgame explorations from the PCL in subsequent weeks. Well, good luck to all of
the teams. Make sure to tune in next week, and I will see you in the next video. Thank you for watching. Hope you enjoyed.